Few of us will make it through life without losing someone we love. Grief, it's been said, is the cost of love. The yearning and sadness we feel after someone dies is the price we sometimes pay for the close relationships that we treasure. Some people are resilient after loss, able to cope with their acute grief and eventually adjust to life without their loved one. Others, meanwhile, find themselves unable to do so. Over the past two decades, researchers have begun using the tools
很少有人能一生平安顺遂，不经历失去挚爱的痛苦。人们常说，悲伤是爱的代价。在某人离世后，我们感到的渴望和悲伤，有时就是我们为那些珍视的亲密关系付出的代价。有些人面对失去时具有韧性，能够应对急性悲伤，并最终适应没有挚爱陪伴的生活。然而，另一些人却发现自己无法做到这一点。在过去的二十年里，研究人员开始运用
of modern neuroscience to better understand why that is, and more broadly to understand what happens to our brains and bodies during the grieving process and how best to help people mourning the death of a loved one. So what makes someone more or less resilient in the face of loss? How is grieving related to depression, and how is it different? What happens to our brains when we are grieving? Is there effective therapy for grief? Is it possible to experience actual grief over the death of a celebrity, and how is that grief different from grief over the loss of a loved one? How can we best support people when they are grieving? Welcome to speaking of psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the
现代神经科学的工具来更好地理解其中的原因，更广泛地了解在悲伤过程中我们的脑和身体会发生什么，以及如何最好地帮助哀悼亲人离世的人。那么，是什么让人在面对失去时更有韧性或更缺乏韧性呢？悲伤与抑郁有何关联，又有何不同？当我们感到悲伤时，我们的大脑会发生什么？是否存在针对悲伤的有效疗法？对名人的死产生真正的悲伤是可能的吗？这种悲伤与因失去亲人而产生的悲伤有何不同？当人们悲伤时，我们如何才能给予他们最好的支持？欢迎收听“心理学对话”（Speaking of Psychology），这是美国心理学协会（American Psychological Association）的旗舰播客，旨在探讨
links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Mary Francis O'Connor, an associate professor of psychology at the University of Arizona, where she studies grief and grieving. She uses methods including brain imaging and studying immune system responses to investigate how grieving affects us both psychologically and physiologically. She is an expert in complicated grief, a clinical condition in which people don't adjust to acute feelings of grief. In addition to her many scientific publications, she is author of the recent book, The Grieving Brain, the Surprising Science of How We Learn from Love and Loss. Thank you for joining us today, Dr. O'Connor.
心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是亚利桑那大学（University of Arizona）心理学副教授玛丽·弗朗西斯·奥康纳（Dr. Mary Francis O'Connor）博士，她在那里研究悲伤和哀悼过程。她运用脑成像和研究免疫系统反应等方法，来调查悲伤如何在心理和生理上影响我们。她是复杂性悲伤（complicated grief）领域的专家，这是一种人们无法适应急性悲伤情绪的临床病症。除了许多科学出版物外，她还是近期出版的新书《悲伤的大脑：我们如何从爱与失落中学习的惊人科学》（The Grieving Brain, the Surprising Science of How We Learn from Love and Loss）的作者。非常感谢今天能作客我们的节目，奥康纳博士。
It's so good to be here. Thanks. One of the points that you make in your book is that grieving is actually a form of learning. Can you explain what that means? I don't think most people think of grieving in that way. This has really come about from years now of studying grief and grieving and reading a lot of studies about what happens when we experience the death of a loved one. And it really has struck me that grieving can be thought of of. form of learning. This is, you know, in a few different ways we can think of it. One is that after we
很高兴来到这里。谢谢。你在书中提出的观点之一是，悲伤实际上是一种学习形式。你能解释一下这是什么意思吗？我想大多数人并不以这种方式看待悲伤。这确实来自于多年来对悲伤和哀悼的研究，以及阅读了大量关于我们经历亲人离世时会发生什么的研究。这真的让我印象深刻，悲伤可以被认为是一种学习的形式。你知道，我们可以从几个不同的角度来思考这个问题。其中之一是，在我们
experience something as difficult as, you know, our one and only passing away, we really have to figure out, how do I live in the world now? What does it mean to retire when, you know, this person that I've been going to do this with for decades is no longer going to do that with me? So part of it is learning to be in the world as a person who carries this absence with them. But even at a smaller level, you can think about all the tiny little habits that we have to change. This is that feeling of, you know, the experience of picking up the phone to call them because something has happened. And then, of course, realizing that we can't call them. So all those little habits and predictions that we have to learn in a new way. Let's talk about the difference between grief and grieving since we're going to be
经历了诸如我们唯一的挚爱离世这样困难的事情之后，我们真的必须弄清楚：我现在该如何在世上生活？当那个和我一起做这件事数十年来的人，以后不再和我一起做这件事时，退休意味着什么？所以，一部分是学习作为一个带着这种缺憾生活的人存在于世。但即使在更微观的层面上，你可以想想我们必须改变的所有微小习惯。这就是那种感觉，你知道，当发生某事时，拿起电话打给他们的经历，然后，当然，意识到我们不能打电话给他们。因此，所有这些微小的习惯和预测，我们都必须以一种新的方式去学习。让我们来谈谈悲伤（grief）和哀悼（grieving）之间的区别，因为在我们对话时会经常
using those terms a lot as we talk. And you've made the point that they're not interchangeable terms. I found it to be helpful in a scientific way to distinguish between grief and grieving. And then as I did that, came to find that other people found it useful as well. So grief really is that feeling that you have, the sort of intensity that. that just overwhelms you and that sort of momentary experience. Grieving, on the other hand, is the way that grief changes over time without ever actually going away. So, for example, the first hundred times you get knocked off your feeling by that feeling
使用这些术语。你曾指出这两个词并非可以互换。我发现在科学上区分“悲伤”和“哀悼”是有帮助的。接着当我这样做的时候，我发现其他人也觉得这很有用。所以，悲伤实际上是你所拥有的那种感觉，那种铺天盖地压倒你的强烈情绪，以及那种短暂的体验。另一方面，哀悼则是悲伤随时间推移而发生变化的方式，但它本身从未真正消失。例如，前一百次你被那种悲伤的
of grief, that wave of grief, the 101st time, it may be just as awful. But it may also be familiar so that now you may have some ways to comfort yourself or you may know how to reach out to someone in that moment. So even though the feeling hasn't necessarily changed, our relationship to the feeling changes over time. And the reason that people have found this to be useful, I think, is if we expect that we're not going to feel grief in the future, that somehow it's going to be over, then we'll be. be disappointed if years later, even decades later, we come across something and suddenly we get all teared up and have that wave of grief. That doesn't mean that we've done anything wrong in our grieving process. It just means that in that moment, we're aware of the loss of something really important. What is the relationship between grief and depression? And can a
感觉、那股悲伤的浪潮击倒时，第一百零一次可能依然同样糟糕。但它也可能变得熟悉，所以现在你可能有一些方法来安慰自己，或者你可能知道在那一刻如何向他人求助。因此，尽管这种感觉本身不一定改变，但我们与这种感觉的关系随时间发生了变化。我认为人们发现这一点很有用的原因在于，如果我们期望未来不会感到悲伤，期望它某种程度上会结束，那么当多年后、甚至几十年后，我们偶然碰到某样东西，突然热泪盈眶并涌起那股悲伤时，我们会感到失望。这并不意味着我们在哀悼过程中做错了什么。这只是意味着在那一刻，我们意识到了失去某件非常重要东西的现实。悲伤与抑郁之间有什么关系？一个人
person grieve without being depressed? The heart of grieving really is. around yearning, yearning for that person to be back or for things to be back the way they were before. And we know now from both diagnostic clinical science, but also brain imaging work, that grief and depression are not the same thing. So we can have both grief and we can have depression just in the same way you could have depression and anxiety, say, for example. But you can have one without the other. In depression, the feelings are usually more global. So while I may feel awful that my loved one isn't here anymore, with depression I will probably
可以在不抑郁的情况下感到悲伤吗？悲伤的核心实际上围绕着渴望——渴望那个人回来，或者渴望事情回到以前的样子。从诊断临床科学和脑成像研究中，我们现在知道，悲伤和抑郁不是一回事。因此，我们既可以感到悲伤，也可以感到抑郁，就像你可能同时患有抑郁症和焦虑症一样。但你可以只有其中之一而没有另一个。在抑郁症中，这些情绪通常更具普遍性。因此，虽然我可能会为挚爱不在人世而感到糟糕，但在抑郁状态下，我可能会
feel awful about a lot of things. I'll feel guilty about things I've done in the past and worried about the way I'm, you know, interacting with people at work and also concerned about the things that I've never fulfilled in my life that I should have done. You know, depression tends to be quite global. Grieving really focuses on that loved one. It's really about I need this person to be back. I can't make it without this person with me. And so is a slightly different experience. You wrote in your new book about how losing a loved one can feel like losing a part of yourself. And you tied that in with the work of Arthur Aaron, who is another psychologist who was recently on this podcast.
对许多事情都感到糟糕。我会为过去做过的事情感到内疚，担心自己与同事互动的方式，还会担忧自己生活中那些从未实现、本该完成的事情。你知道，抑郁往往是相当普遍的。而悲伤则真正聚焦于那个挚爱的人。它真正关乎的是：我需要这个人回来，没有这个人陪伴我，我无法撑下去。因此，这是一种略有不同的体验。你在新书中写到，失去挚爱可能感觉像是失去了自我的一部分。你将这一点与另一位心理学家亚瑟·阿伦（Arthur Aaron）的工作联系起来，他最近也做客了这个播客。
Can you talk about that connection? Why do we experience loss this way? Well, to think about what happens when we lose a loved one? You have to first recognize that the brain encodes a bond when you fall in love with your spouse or with your child. the brain encodes this bond. Essentially, it creates a we, not just a you and a me, but it creates a we of overlapping experience. And because of that then, when a loved one is no longer there, we actually experience it as part of us as missing, right? So at a very neural and coded level, our representation of the we has a hole in it. It's not just the metaphorical way, perhaps, that we describe feeling like there's a hole in our heart. And so with that, then,
你能谈谈这种联系吗？为什么我们会有这样的失落体验？嗯，要思考当我们失去挚爱时会发生什么，你首先必须认识到，当你爱上配偶或孩子时，大脑会编码一种纽带。大脑会编码这种纽带。本质上，它创造了一个“我们”，而不仅仅是你和我，它创造了一个重叠体验的“我们”。正因如此，当挚爱不在了，我们实际上会将其体验为我们自身的一部分缺失了，对吧？因此，在一个非常神经编码的层面上，“我们”的表征中出现了一个洞。这不仅仅是我们用来形容感觉心中有个洞的隐喻方式。因此，带着这一点，
we come to understand differently, perhaps, and can consider things like phantom limb syndrome, right, where people who have had an arm or part of a leg amputated, they sometimes experience itching or pain in that absent limb. And we know it's because the brain has not rewired its representation of the body. And so we're actually experiencing sensations in the brain that aren't related to peripheral nerves. I think that we're coming to discover, the way that we gets encoded might mean that we continue to expect to have both parts of we as we function in the world and then experience it as a great loss, as a missing, as an absence, when they're not there with us. And so is there a kind of rewiring then that happens in the
我们或许能以不同的方式去理解，并思考诸如幻肢综合征（phantom limb syndrome）之类的情况，对吧？那些被截肢手臂或部分腿部的人，有时会在那个缺失的肢体上感到瘙痒或疼痛。我们知道这是因为大脑没有重新布线其对身体的表征。因此，我们实际上是在大脑中体验到与外周神经无关的感觉。我认为我们正在发现，“我们”被编码的方式可能意味着，当我们在这个世界运作时，我们继续期望拥有“我们”的两个部分，而当他们不在我们身边时，则将其体验为巨大的损失、缺失和缺席。那么，在我们失去某人之后，大脑中是否会发生一种重新布线呢？
brain after we lose someone? There is. And some of what we know about, this is actually from the work of Zoe Donaldson at the University of Colorado Boulder. She studies voles, these little rodents who mate for life. And because they mate for life, it gives us an opportunity to really investigate from a neuroscience perspective, what happens then if a mate goes missing in this vole couple? And what we know is that there is extensive change in the brain when the body. bond is originally formed. There are changes to the way the proteins are folded in the nucleus accumbens of the brain, this little part of the reward network in the brain. And then when time
确实会。我们所了解的一些情况，实际上来自于科罗拉多大学博尔德分校（University of Colorado Boulder）佐伊·唐纳森（Zoe Donaldson）的研究。她研究田鼠，这些终生一夫一妻的小型啮齿动物。因为它们终生伴侣不变，这让我们有机会从神经科学的角度真正探究：如果在这个田鼠伴侣中有一方失踪了，会发生什么？我们所知道的是，当身体纽带最初形成时，大脑会发生广泛的变化。大脑伏隔核中的蛋白质折叠方式会发生变化，伏隔核是大脑奖励网络中的这个小部分。然后，当时间
passes, there are these neurons that are devoted to firing when we approach a mate, right? And as the bond grows stronger, we have more and more of these neurons, just signifying how important it is that this function of seeking out our maid and spending time with them get so much resources of the brain. And then upon separation, we see all the physiological changes that happen, the stress hormones that increase like cortisol or corticosterone in animals. And we see dopamine and oxytose really trying to motivate us to find them again. And over time, then, there are neurocestrone. and transcriptional changes that happen in the brain as the voles try to understand what has
流逝，有这些专门负责在我们接近伴侣时发放冲动的神经元，对吧？随着纽带变得越发强烈，我们拥有越来越多这样的神经元，这正说明了寻求伴侣并与他们共度时光这一功能占用大脑如此多的资源是多么重要。随后在分离时，我们看到了发生的所有生理变化，应激激素（如动物体内的皮质醇或皮质酮）增加。我们看到多巴胺和催产素真正试图激励我们再次找到它们。随着时间的推移，当田鼠试图理解发生了
happened and the analogy then to humans, although we have an additional two pounds of brain, so it's more complex certainly than for vols. But nonetheless, I think we're seeing how the brain has to really update and change, and that that's partly a mechanical process, and all of that takes time. So much of your work is on what's called complicated grief. What's the difference between complicated grief and just everyday grief? Yeah, I like the term complicated grief, but I have to be honest with the listeners. The term that's been chosen by the DSM, the diagnostic and statistical manual is prolonged grief disorder, and that's been recently adopted, actually, within the last
什么时，大脑中会发生神经雌激素和转录变化。类比到人类身上，尽管我们多出两磅重的大脑，所以它当然比田鼠更复杂。但尽管如此，我认为我们看到大脑如何必须真正更新和改变，这部分是一个机械过程，而这一切都需要时间。你的很多工作都是关于所谓的“复杂性悲伤”。复杂性悲伤与日常悲伤有什么区别？是的，我喜欢“复杂性悲伤”这个词，但我必须对听众坦诚。精神障碍诊断与统计手册（DSM）选择的术语是“持续性复杂悲伤障碍”（prolonged grief disorder），这个词实际上是最近才被采纳的，就在过去
year. The reason that I like the term complicated grief, and really researchers are looking at the same phenomena when they, almost the same phenomenon when they use both terms, but complicated grief to me reminds me that we're talking about complications. So here's an analogy that may help. If you break a bone, we don't actually do something to knit those cells back together, right? That's a natural healing process that happens, although we might do something to support that process. So we may wear a cast, for example, to give it support or use crutches, right, to give a little extra resources.
一年里。我喜欢“复杂性悲伤”这个词的原因是——实际上研究人员在使用这两个术语时研究的是同一种现象，几乎是同一种现象——但复杂性悲伤对我而言是个提醒，提醒我们在谈论并发症。这里有一个可能有所帮助的类比。如果你骨折了，我们其实不会做什么来把那些细胞重新编织缝合在一起，对吧？那是一个自然发生的愈合过程，尽管我们可能会做些事情来支持这个过程。例如，我们可以打石膏来提供支撑，或者使用拐杖，对吧，来提供一点额外的资源。
And that's a natural process unless sometimes we have complications where there's a an infection in the area that's trying to heal, or perhaps there's a secondary break in the bone. And under those circumstances, it can be very helpful for intervention to go in and help get that bone back on its typical healing trajectory. So the analogy then is that I think grief is a natural response to loss. It just, it is what our brain, our mind, our body does in reality. action. And the vast majority of us are quite resilient. We know from the work of George Bonano that the vast majority of us will find a way to sort of restore this meaningful life, find a way to, you know, continue loving our grandkids and getting dinner on the table and getting out to the
这是一个自然的过程，除非有时我们遇到并发症，比如正在愈合的区域受到感染，或者骨头发生了二次骨折。在这种情况下，进行干预以帮助骨头回到其典型的愈合轨迹上，是非常有帮助的。因此，这个类比就是，我认为悲伤是对失去的自然反应。它只是、它正是我们的脑、我们的心、我们的身体在面对现实时所做的事情。绝大多数人都相当有韧性。从乔治·博纳诺（George Bonano）的研究中我们得知，绝大多数人都会找到方法来恢复这种有意义的生活，找到方法，你知道的，继续爱他们的孙辈、把晚饭端上餐桌、去
grocery store, all those things. The difficulty comes when we can get derailed in that process. and prolonged grief disorder and the interventions that have been developed to treat prolonged grief disorder really focus on trying to build new skills in a person who's been derailed in their natural grieving process and by enabling them to use these new skills to get back on that healing trajectory. So intervention is not designed to get them to stop grieving. That's not, that's not the idea, but rather to take care of ways they've become derailed, particular thoughts they're having, behaviors they're engaged in that are not helping as they're trying courageously to move forward. And by intervening in this way, we know now some of the terrific work by Kathy Shear at Columbia
杂货店，所有这些事情。困难在于，我们在那个过程中可能会偏离轨道。持续性复杂悲伤障碍以及为治疗持续性复杂悲伤障碍而开发的干预措施，真正专注于为那些在自然哀悼过程中偏离轨道的人建立新技能，通过使他们能够利用这些新技能回到那个愈合轨迹上来。因此，干预并不是为了让他们停止悲伤。那不是、那不是我们的主意，而是为了处理他们偏离轨道的方式，比如他们正在产生的特定想法、他们参与的、在他们勇敢向前迈进时并无帮助的行为。通过以这种方式进行干预，我们现在从哥伦比亚大学
University, we know now that we can intervene effectively for folks who've had prolonged grief disorder for a decade, they still benefit from this type of psychotherapy. And is it just directing people to think differently? Is it like cognitive behavioral therapy? Are you given exercises to kind of keep you from ruminating? I mean, what are you trying to do with the person who has this disorder? There are a few different aspects to it in prolonged grief disorder treatment that she has developed. It's a manualized therapy. And it includes, a number of things. One of them is really focusing on the loss. Many of us, even when we talk about how awful grief feels, that's still different than focusing on what happened at the moment of death
凯茜·谢尔（Kathy Shear）的一些极佳研究中得知，我们现在可以对那些患有持续性持续性复杂悲伤障碍达十年之久的人进行有效的干预，他们仍然能从这种心理治疗中受益。这仅仅是引导人们做不同的思考吗？这就像认知行为疗法吗？你会得到一些练习来防止自己反刍思维吗？我的意思是，对于患有这种障碍的人，你究竟在尝试做什么？在凯茜开发的持续性复杂悲伤障碍治疗中，有几个不同的方面。这是一套手册化的疗法。它包含许多内容。其中之一是真正聚焦于失去。我们许多人，甚至在我们谈论悲伤感觉有多糟糕时，这仍然不同于聚焦于死亡那一刻发生的事情
or when we realized the finality that this person just wasn't coming back. For many people, they need more exposure to those memories to really understand what happened and how they understand the experience. So they'll do types of what we might recognize as exposure therapy, where clients will talk about it and have that recorded and then listen to it, while developing skills of how do I move into the feeling of grief and then out of it again, developing new skills around emotion regulation, developing skills around acceptance. But other things as well, the other aspect isn't just focusing on the loss, but focusing, as I say, on restoring what is life like for you now.
，或者是当我们意识到这个人真的不会再回来了这一最终结论时的时刻。对许多人来说，他们需要更多地接触这些记忆，以真正理解发生了什么以及他们如何理解这段经历。因此，他们会做我们可能认为是暴露疗法的事情，客户端会谈论此事并将其录音，然后边听录音边培养技能：我如何进入悲伤的情绪然后再走出来？围绕情绪调节培养新技能，围绕接纳培养技能。但还有其他事情，另一个方面不仅是聚焦于失去，就像我说的，还要聚焦于恢复：你现在的生活是什么样的？
And many people, because grief is so painful, have come to avoid situations or reminders or people associated with their deceased loved one. And the trouble with avoidance is it tends to spread, right? So we start avoiding a small number of things, and then we start to avoid more and more things that remind us of these painful grief feelings. From the perspective of the brain, if we're going to learn what life is like now,
许多人因为悲伤太痛苦，而开始回避与他们已故挚爱相关的情境、提醒或人。回避的问题在于它往往会蔓延，对吧？所以我们开始回避一小部分事情，然后我们开始回避越来越多提醒我们这些痛苦悲伤情绪的事情。从大脑的角度来看，如果我们想要了解现在的生活是什么样的，
and we're going to learn what makes sense for us, what can be meaningful, we have to engage in new experiences. That's how the brain learns. And so the therapy helps to come up with possibilities, things that you might be avoiding, and also things that you might try now. And by giving people the support and encouragement,
并且我们要了解什么对我们来说是有意义的、说得通的，我们就必须参与新的体验。大脑就是这样学习的。因此，疗法有助于提出各种可能性——你可能一直在回避的事情，以及你现在可以尝试的事情。通过给予人们支持和鼓励，
sometimes even permission to engage in new behaviors, their brain does learn that life is full of many possibilities. And the final piece is really working, with the support system of the person who's grieving so that they understand what this person is going through and that they can provide that sort of courageous support and also, you know, not back away from the intensity of the grieving person's feelings. So when many people think of grieving, what comes to mind is Elizabeth Kubler-Ross's five stages of grief, right? Denial, anger, bargaining, depression, and then, finally,
有时甚至给予参与新行为的许可，他们的大脑确实会认识到生活充满了许多可能性。最后一部分是真正与悲伤者的支持系统合作，让他们理解这个人正在经历什么，并提供那种勇敢的支持，同时，你知道的，不要退缩面对悲伤者情绪的强烈程度。因此，当许多人想到悲伤时，浮现脑海的是伊丽莎白·库伯勒-罗斯（Elizabeth Kubler-Ross）的悲伤五阶段，对吧？否认、愤怒、讨价还价、抑郁，然后最后是
acceptance. But you've written that these stages aren't an accurate picture of how people grieve. So how did the five stages become the standard of how we think of grieving? And is there any part of that model that you believe makes sense? Well, this is a great example, I think, of how making the distinction between grief and grieving can be so useful. So I have just enormous misrespect for Dr. Elizabeth Kubler-Ross, who's a psychiatrist working in the 1960s, a woman in her field when there were not many women in her field. And she did what any good scientist does when they are working with a phenomena. She described, right? So she had this revolutionary idea that we could talk to terminally ill people, that we could ask them what their experience was like.
接受。但你写过，这些阶段并不是人们悲伤方式的准确写照。那么，这五个阶段是如何成为我们对悲伤看法的标准的呢？你认为这个模型的哪一部分是有道理的呢？嗯，我认为这是一个很好的例子，说明区分悲伤（grief）和哀悼（grieving）是多么有用。我对伊丽莎白·库伯勒-罗斯博士怀有无比的敬意，她是一位在20世纪60年代工作的精神病学家，在那个女性稀少的领域里她是一名女性。她做了一位优秀的科学家在研究某种现象时所做的事情。她进行了描述，对吧？所以她有一个革命性的想法：我们可以与绝症患者交谈，我们可以询问他们的体验是怎样的。
And then she trained other medical residents and chaplains and social workers and psychologists and doctors, to also talk with terminally ill people and find out what their grief was like. And this was then also applied to bereave people as well. So she described grief in a very accurate way. Anger is a part of grief, isn't it? And depression is often a part of the feelings of grief. What makes it difficult, and we know now from some of the more recent work by Jason Holland and Bob B. Meyer, who looked at the trajectory of grieving over time. So the difference between just
然后她训练其他医学住院医师、牧师、社工、心理学家和医生，也去和绝症患者交谈，了解他们的悲伤是怎样的。这后来也被应用到了失去亲人的人身上。因此，她以非常准确的方式描述了悲伤。愤怒是悲伤的一部分，不是吗？抑郁也常常是悲伤情绪的一部分。是什么让这变得困难呢？我们现在从杰森·霍兰德（Jason Holland）和鲍勃·B·迈耶（Bob B. Meyer）最近的一些研究中得知，他们观察了悲伤随时间的轨迹——也就是仅仅
what the moment felt like the anger, say, for example, someone is expressing, compared to how that anger might change if you interviewed the same person multiple times across a year or a couple of years of their life. And so what we know now is that there isn't a linear, process. We don't do all of depression and then we get to all of acceptance, but rather, over time, research suggests that yearning declines and that acceptance increases, but that this doesn't happen in a stair step kind of way. Rather, we know, for example, that at anniversaries or at the holidays, people tend to have a resurgence of grief. And that doesn't mean that their grieving trajectory isn't still going in the right direction, it just means that these are moments where people
那一刻的感觉（比如某人表达的愤怒）与如果你在一年或几年的生活中多次采访同一个人时该愤怒可能如何改变之间的区别。所以我们现在知道，这不是一个线性的过程。我们不会经历完所有的抑郁，然后就完全到达接受，而是随着时间推移，研究表明渴望会减弱，接受会增加，但这并不是以阶梯式的方式发生的。相反，我们知道，例如在周年纪念日或节日里，人们往往会迎来悲伤的复发。但这并不意味着他们的哀悼轨迹没有朝着正确的方向发展，这只是意味着在这些时刻，人们
are aware of their grief. So if we use it as a description, I think that that works well. If we use it as a prescription for how to grieve, I think it often doesn't fit people's experience, and it doesn't mean their experiences is wrong in any way. We recently had another episode with psychologist Dr. Pauline Boss, who was an expert on what she termed ambiguous loss. That is loss where a loved one is physically absent, but there's no body, like a prisoner of war, or where a person is physically present, but mentally absent, as in dementia. Do our brains process ambiguous losses differently than they do a more clear-cut loss like an actual death? It's such important work, and I think people really resonate
意识到了他们的悲伤。因此，如果我们把它当作一种描述，我认为这很有效。如果我们把它当作如何悲伤的处方，我认为它往往不符合人们的体验，这并不意味着他们的体验在任何方面是错误的。我们最近有一期节目采访了心理学家保琳·博斯（Pauline Boss）博士，她是她所称的“模棱两可的失落”（ambiguous loss）领域的专家。那是这样一种失落：亲人身体不在，但没有尸体，比如战俘；或者一个人身体在，但精神不在，比如患有痴呆症。我们的大脑处理模棱两可的失落，与处理像真正死亡这样更明确的失落时有什么不同吗？这是一项非常重要的工作，我认为人们对这种模棱两可的失落的概念深有共鸣，
with this idea of ambiguous loss because it is so challenging. So as I described before, even in a very clear-cut case where we were there when the person died, we already are dealing with sort of these two streams of information that are in conflict with each other. So on the one hand, we have the memory of being at the bedside of knowing that this person has died. And on the other hand, because of this bond that we formed, the way that we encode attachment is that this person will always be here for me and I will always be here for them. And we don't actually have to be in someone's presence in order for us to have that attachment of belief, right?
因为它太具挑战性了。正如我之前所描述的，甚至在一个非常明确的案例中——我们在亲人去世时就在场——我们已经在应对相互冲突的两股信息流。一方面，我们有在病床旁的记忆，知道这个人已经去世了。另一方面，由于我们形成的这种纽带，我们编码依恋的方式是：这个人将永远为我在这里，我也将永远为他们在这里。我们其实并不需要身处某人的陪伴中才能拥有那种依恋信念，对吧？
You wouldn't be able to send your kids to school every day if you didn't, you know, know, know deeply at the end of the day we'll all be back. So they're going to come back. Exactly, that they're all going to be back at home at night. And so that attachment belief really doesn't rely on the presence of the person. Well, even in a clear-cut case of grieving, these two things conflict initially, don't they? We have a memory on the one hand, and on the other hand, this is an everlasting relationship. And the solution is just to go find them if they're not in our presence.
如果你不是在内心深处知道到了傍晚大家都会回来，你就无法每天把孩子送到学校去。所以他们会回来的。没错，他们晚上都会回到家里。因此，这种依恋信念其实并不依赖于那个人的在场。好吧，即使在一个明确的悲伤案例中，这两件事最初也是冲突的，不是吗？一方面我们有记忆，另一方面这是一段永恒的关系。而如果他们不在我们身边，解决办法就是去找他们。
So that, I think, causes a lot of disorientation and is part of why it takes so long to grieve. Now, if you add on top of all that difficulty and uncertainty, where you don't have memories of that person, of seeing their body at a funeral, of having a graveside to go to, then it makes the grieving even more complex, even more discerpt, even more discerable. orienting or potentially takes even longer. So while I think that we experience the feelings of grief, just as we would in a case of clear-cut death, there are all these additional layers that then come along with it. It's a little bit related in a sense that when people grieve about a celebrity who died, someone they greatly admired. It's not a physical loss in the same way because you didn't have an actual relationship with the person other than the one you had in your mind. And you've termed this parisocial grief.
所以，我认为这会导致很多迷失方向，这也是为什么哀悼需要这么长时间的部分原因。现在，如果在所有这些困难和不确定性的基础上，你没有那个人的记忆——没有在葬礼上看到他们的遗体、没有可以去扫墓的墓地——那么这会使哀悼变得更加复杂，更加令人无所适从、更加迷失方向，或者可能需要更长的时间。因此，虽然我认为我们体验到的悲伤感觉与在明确死亡案例中一样，但还有所有这些额外的层面随之而来。这在某种程度上有相似之处，当人们为一个过世的名人（他们非常钦佩的人）感到悲伤时。这并不是传统意义上的物理失落，因为你与这个人并没有实际的关系，除了你在心中构建的那段关系。你将此称为“准社会悲伤”（parasocial grief）。
How is it that we can feel intensity of grief with someone like that, a celebrity, someone we admired who has passed away? This is a fascinating phenomenon, isn't it? We see when someone who's a famous actor or a musician dies, just this outpouring of grief often. And it seems almost incomprehensible. How are these individuals who did not know this person so moved that they, would come to a place and leave flowers and like candles. And you even just hear people describe or perhaps have felt yourself that pang that really sticks with you when a celebrity or an actor or a musician has died.
为什么我们能对这样的人——一个过世的名人、我们钦佩的人——产生强烈的悲伤情绪呢？这是一个迷人的现象，不是吗？当一位著名的演员或音乐家去世时，我们经常看到这种悲伤的倾泻。这几乎令人难以理解。这些并不认识这个人的人，怎么会被触动到来到某个地方献上鲜花、点燃蜡烛？你甚至听到人们描述，或者你自己也曾感受到，当一位名人、演员或音乐家去世时，那种真正挥之不去的刺痛感。
And I think it relates to exactly what you were saying, while there's no official relationship that could be pointed to from the outside. And certainly we know that person doesn't know us. On the other hand, many of those art forms, they provide us a way to access some of our inner emotions. Think about the way musicians will write lyrics and we think, oh my goodness, how could they know that about me? Right? That really describes exactly how I feel. And I think that is a kind of bonding that happens.
我认为这与你刚才所说的正相关，虽然从外部来看无法指出任何官方的关系，而且我们当然知道那个人并不认识我们。另一方面，其中许多艺术形式为我们提供了一种途径，来接触我们内心的一些情感。想想音乐家写歌词的方式，我们会想：哦天哪，他们怎么会对我了解得这么透彻？对吧？那真的准确描述了我的感受。我认为这是一种发生的连接。
And often these relationships, I'll call them, these connections to actors and musicians happen at times in our life where we really are trying to find the words for how we feel inside. So that time that we have spent binge watching an actor or spent time, you know, listening over and over and over again to music, I think in a sense that is a kind of bonding. And therefore, that parasycial grief means that we lose a person who really understood the way we see the world. And we often associate that with a particular time in our life, right? So if a musician dies that I listen to, you know, all through college, I feel a little piece of my college self has gone as well that I'll never have again, you know? Yeah, yeah, we're very nostalgic. Yeah, I can understand that loss. So I've heard you say in some interviews that grief or bereavement is a health disparity.
而且通常这些关系——我称之为连接——对演员和音乐家的这种连接发生在我们生命的某些时期，那时我们真的在为自己内心的感受寻找词汇。因此，我们花时间狂刷某个演员作品的时期，或者一遍又一遍聆听音乐的时期，我认为在某种意义上这也是一种连接。因此，这种准社会悲伤意味着我们失去了一个真正理解我们看待世界方式的人。我们经常将此与我们生命中的特定时期联系起来，对吧？所以，如果我整个大学期间都在听的某个音乐家去世了，我觉得我大学时的一小部分也随之消失了，再也找不回来了，你知道吗？是的，是的，我们非常怀旧。是的，我能理解那种失落。所以，我听你在一些采访中说，悲伤或失去亲人是一种健康差异（health disparity）。
What do you mean by that? Well, we don't often think of it that way, but we know that mortality is, of course, different in different communities. So rates of mortality really became clear during the COVID pandemic how different it was affecting minorityized communities. black, indigenous, and people of color. And so we forget then that the result of that is that bereavement is also a health disparity. So even just taking the example of COVID, we know that black American children were over twice as likely to experience the death of a caregiver compared to white American children. And for American Indian children, it was more than four times more likely to experience the death of a caregiver. And so if you think about health equity, then, if we talk about grieving at a public health level,
这是什么意思？嗯，我们不常这样想，但我们知道不同群体的死亡率当然是不同的。在新冠疫情期间，死亡率的差异变得非常明显，它对边缘化群体（黑人、原住民和有色人种）产生了如此不同的影响。因此，我们忘记了其结果是，失去亲人也是一种健康差异。因此，仅以新冠疫情为例，我们知道美国黑人儿童失去照顾者的可能性是美国白人儿童的两倍以上。对于美洲印第安儿童来说，失去照顾者的可能性是其四倍多。因此，如果你考虑健康公平，那么如果我们从公共卫生层面来谈论悲伤，
at a social, cultural level, then it's important for us to have resources applied in a way that allows us all to process our grieving in a healthy way. And that may mean putting more resources in some places than others to bring everyone to the same level of having opportunities to grieve and experience support. I think it's an important policy aspect to consider how are we applying grief education in schools? How are we offering counseling? What kinds of, you know, even apps might we create that are culturally informed so that people who are in different communities can find what they need in order to grieve in a healthy way. People often find it hard to know what to do, to support someone who is grieving.
从社会、文化的层面来谈论，重要的是我们要以某种方式投入资源，让我们所有人都能以健康的方式处理悲伤。这可能意味着在某些地方投入比其他地方更多的资源，使每个人都达到享有哀悼和体验支持机会的相同水平。我认为这是一个重要的政策层面，需要考虑我们如何在学校中应用悲伤教育？我们如何提供咨询？我们甚至可以创建什么样的、植根于文化的应用程序，以便不同社区的人们能够找到他们所需的东西，从而以健康的方式悲伤。人们经常发现很难知道该做什么来支持一个正在悲伤的人。
What are the right words to say, the right kind of support to provide? And is that something you can look at, for example, when you're doing brain research so that you know what is making people feel better? This is quite difficult. being with a person who is grieving, there's an intensity that is quite difficult to sit with. People are having some of the worst experiences of their life. They will describe it that way often, and often quite unexpected as well. So we very frequently don't know what grief will feel like until we've walked through that door. And so the difficulty is, that especially in our culture, I think our goal often when we are trying to provide support
正确的话语是什么，该提供什么样的正确支持？当你做大脑研究时，例如是否可以观察这一点，以便了解是什么让人感觉好一些？这相当困难。陪伴一个正在悲伤的人，有一种很难与之共处的强烈情绪。人们正在经历他们一生中最糟糕的一些经历。他们经常会这样描述，而且往往也非常出乎意料。所以我们非常经常地在穿过那扇门之前，并不知道悲伤会是什么感觉。因此，困难在于，特别是在我们的文化中，我认为当我们试图为悲伤的人提供支持时，我们的目标往往是
for a grieving person, the goal we have in mind is to cheer them up, right? We don't want them to feel this intense grief. Well, let's think about that for a second from the perspective of a grieving person. So for a grieving person, they're often having this unexpected experience that's really intense, like the emotion dial just got turned way up. And, now they're sitting with someone who's trying to help them to get into a different state than they are in, right? It's trying to cheer them up. I think for many grieving people, that feels even more alienating.
让他们振作起来，对吧？我们不希望他们感受到这种强烈的悲伤。好吧，从悲伤者的角度思考一下这个问题。对一个悲伤的人来说，他们经常有这种意料之外的、非常强烈的体验，就像情感拨号盘被调得非常高。而现在，他们正和某个试图帮他们进入不同状态（即尝试让他们振作起来）的人坐在一起。我认为对许多悲伤的人来说，这感觉更加疏离。
I'm already having a difficult time experiencing what I am experiencing. And now there's sort of a disconnect if I'm supposed to act as though I feel okay or as though what you're saying has made everything okay in the world again. And so I think our goal, perhaps, isn't so much to cheer them up, but to simply be with them. What is it that they're learning about what life is like now? What is it that they're learning about how grief feels? Are we able to just be with them? And to let them know that we will be with them however long and whatever shape this takes. And, you know, I'll be perfectly honest. I've, I've worked with a lot of grieving people. I feel comfortable when people cry uncontrollably. And I still say things that I think,
我已经很难去体验我正在经历的一切了，而现在如果我必须表现得好像我感觉很好，或者表现得好像你所说的话让世上的一切再次变得美好，这就产生了一种脱节。因此，我认为我们的目标也许不是让他们振作起来，而是简单地陪伴他们。他们关于“现在的生活是什么样的”学到了什么？关于悲伤是什么感觉，他们学到了什么？我们能否只是陪伴他们？并让他们知道，无论这需要多久、无论它呈现什么形状，我们都会陪伴他们。而且，你知道的，说句实话。我曾与许多悲伤的人共事。当人们无法控制地哭泣时，我感到很自在。但我仍然会说出一些让我觉得
oh my gosh, that sounded so insensitive, you know. And so I try to just say to people, look, I don't know why I said that. I'm sorry. You know, that probably didn't sound. That didn't make any sense to you. I'd rather just find out what will be useful to you. Do you want to just go for a drive and not talk at all? Do you want to just pretend this hasn't happened and, you know, go to the movies? Or do you want to talk about it and tell me when it's like a friend recently, a part of my circle of friends, he had experienced the death of his mom. And he sort of blew up and, you know, anger after this thing we had all been at together. And our friends were sort of like, what's wrong with him, you know? And I said, guys, he just,
“哦天哪，听起来太不近人情了”之类的话，你知道的。所以我尽量对人们说：听着，我不知道我为什么那样说。我很抱歉。你知道，那可能听起来不对。这对你没有任何意义。我宁愿弄清楚什么对你有用。你想只是去兜风而什么都不说吗？你想假装这没有发生过，去看电影吗？还是你想谈谈它，告诉我它是什么样的？最近有个朋友，在我的朋友圈子里，他经历了母亲的去世。我们在经历了一次聚会后，他有点情绪爆发了，你知道的，在发生那件事后他很愤怒，我们的朋友们有点像：他怎么了？你知道的。我说：伙计们，他刚刚
lost someone a couple months ago. Everything is a little on edge for him. And, you know, just giving him a little extra TLC and a little extra benefit of the doubt goes a long way. So what are you researching now? What are the next questions that you want to answer? Well, one of the things that the distinction between grief and grieving has led to, is an understanding that much of our neuroimaging work studies grief. It studies that moment. So in the scanner, bereaved people have brought us photos often of the deceased person. And we can scan those so that in the neuroimaging scanner, they're looking at a photo of their loved one on goggles
在几个月前失去了亲人。他的情绪有点处于边缘。而且，你知道的，只要多给他一点关爱和多一点信任，就会大有帮助。那么你现在在研究什么？你接下来想回答什么问题呢？嗯，悲伤（grief）和哀悼（grieving）之间的区别所带来的结果之一，就是人们认识到我们的大脑成像研究大多是在研究悲伤。它研究的是那一刻。所以在扫描仪里，失去亲的人经常给我们带来死者的照片。我们可以扫描这些照片，这样在脑成像扫描仪里，他们戴着护目镜看着挚爱的照片，
and comparing that, say, to looking at a photo of a stranger. So, you know, we have some ways to elicit this grief for stress. response moment. But what we don't have many studies of yet is what changes over time? If we were to scan the same person multiple times across the first year or two of their grieving experience, we might see some things that change. Now, there are a few studies like this, but very few. And I think that would help us to understand more about what a typical trajectory looks like, perhaps what it looks like when people don't have that increase in acceptance and decrease in yearning. So that's one of the methods I think we have to look forward to to to understand more.
并将其与看陌生人的照片进行比较。所以，你知道的，我们有一些方法来引发这种悲伤的应激反应时刻。但是我们还没有很多关于“什么随时间改变”的研究。如果我们对同一个人在他们哀悼体验的第一年或两年内进行多次扫描，我们可能会看到一些会发生变化的事情。现在，有一些这样的研究，但非常少。我认为这将有助于我们更多地了解典型的轨迹是什么样的，或者当人们没有出现接受度的增加和渴望度的减少时，它看起来是什么样的。所以这是我期待研究以了解更多的方向之一。
Well, Dr. O'Connor, thank you for joining me today. This has been really interesting and I hope it will be helpful to our listeners. Thank you. Thank you so much. Thanks for bringing this important conversation to folks. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www.combeingof Psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you're listening on Apple, please leave us a review.
好了，奥康纳博士，谢谢你今天加入我的节目。这真的非常有趣，我希望这对我们的听众会有所帮助。谢谢。非常感谢。谢谢你把这个重要的对话带给大家。你可以在我们的网站 www.combeingof Psychology.org 上，或者在 Apple、Stitcher 或你获取播客的任何地方找到“心理学对话”往期的节目。如果你在 Apple 上收听，请给我们留下一条评论。
If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speakingof psychology at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condiom. Thank you for listening for the American Psychology. Association. I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至 speakingof psychology at APA.org。本期“心理学对话”由李·韦内曼（Lee Weinerman）制作。我们的音频编辑是克里斯·康迪奥姆（Chris Condiom）。感谢收听美国心理学协会（American Psychology Association）的节目。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。